welcome back and if you were covering
your eyes because you didn't want to see
calculus i think you can open your eyes
again
there shouldn't be any significant um
displays of calculus in this video but
just to review what we went over we just
said okay if we have a spring and i drew
it vertically this time but pretend like
there's no gravity or maybe pretend like
we're you know reviewing we're looking
at at the top of a table because we we
don't want to look at the effect of a
spring and gravity we just want to look
at a spring by itself so this could be
in deep space or or something else but
we're not thinking about gravity but i
do it vertically just so that we can get
more intuition for this curve what we
started off saying is if i have a spring
and 0
x equals 0 is kind of the natural
resting point of the spring if i just
let this mass if i didn't pull on the
spring at all but i have a mass attached
to spring and if i were to stretch the
spring to point a we used we said well
what happens well it'll it starts with
with very little velocity but there's a
restorative force that's going to be
pulling it back towards this position so
that force will accelerate the mass
accelerate the mass accelerate the mass
until it gets right here and then i'll
have a lot of velocity here but the
change in but then it'll start
decelerating and then it'll decelerate
decelerate decelerate its velocity will
stop and it'll come back up and if we
drew this as a function of time this is
what happens it it starts moving very
slowly accelerates at this point at x
equals zero it has its maximum speed so
the rate of change of velocity or the
the rate of change of of a position is
fastest and we can see the slope is very
fast right here
and then at and then we start slowing
down again slowing down until we get
back to this bottom a and then we keep
going back and up and down up and down
like that
and we showed that actually the equation
for the masses position as a function of
time
is well
x of t and we use a little bit of
differential equations to prove it
but this equation not that i recommend
that you memorize anything but this is a
pretty useful equation to memorize
because
you can use it to pretty much figure out
anything
about the position
or the of the mass at any given time or
or the frequency of this oscillatory
motion or or anything else you even knew
the velocity if you know a little bit of
calculus you can figure out the velocity
any time of the object and that's that's
pretty neat
so so what can we do um now
well let's try to figure out the period
of of this of this
of this
oscillating system and just so you know
i i know i put the label harmonic motion
on all these this is simple harmonic
motion simple harmonic motion is
something that
can be described by a trigonometric
function like this and it just
oscillates back and forth back and forth
and so what we're doing is harmonic
motion and now let's figure out what
this period is remember we said that
after t seconds it gets back to its
original position and then after another
t seconds it gets back to its original
position let's figure out what this t is
and and that's essentially it's period
right what's the period of a function
especially it's how long it takes to get
back to your starting point or how long
it it takes for the whole cycle to to
happen once
so what is this t
so let me ask you a question what are
all the points that if this is a cosine
function right
what are all of the points at which
cosine is equal to
1 or this function would be equal to a
right because whenever cosine is equal
to 1 this whole function is equal to a
as these points well cosine is equal to
1 when
so
theta let's say when is cosine
when is cosine of theta
equal to one so what angles is is this
true
well it's true if theta is equal to zero
right cosine of zero is one
cosine of two pi is also 1 right we
could just keep going around that unit
circle you should watch the unit circle
video if this makes no sense to you or
the graphing trig functions
it's also true at 4 pi
really any multiple of of 2 pi
this is true
right cosine of that of of that angle is
equal to 1.
so the same thing is true this function
x of t
is equal to
a
at what points x of t is equal to a
whenever this expression within the
cosines within the
whenever this expression is equal to 0
2 pi
4 pi
etc and this first time that it cycles
right from 0 to 2 pi
from 0 to t that'll be at 2 pi
right
so this whole expression will equal a
when
k and that's these points right that's
when this function is equal to a and
i'll happen to get over here someplace
when this little internal expression is
equal to 2 pi or really any multiple of
2 pi so we could say
when so x of t is equal to a when square
root
of k over m
times t
is equal to 2 pi
or another way of thinking about it is
let's multiply both sides of this
equation times
the inverse of the square root of k over
m
and you get
t
is equal to
2 pi
times the square root and it's going to
be the inverse of this right of
m over k
and there we have
the period of this function this is
going to be equal to 2 pi
times the square root of m over k
so if you
if if someone tells you well i have a um
i have a a a spring that i'm going to
pull from some you know i'm going to
stretch it or compress it a little bit
and then i let go what is the period how
long does it take for the spring to go
uh back to its original position and
it'll keep doing that assuming we have
no friction or no gravity or any air
resistance or anything like that air
resistance really is just a form of
friction you can immediately if you
memorize this formula although you
should know where it comes from you
should you could immediately say well i
know how long the period is it's 2 pi
times m over k that's how long it's
going to take the spring to get back to
complete one cycle
and then what's what about the frequency
if you wanted to know cycles per second
well that's just the inverse of the
period
right so if i want to know the frequency
that equals one over the period
right period is given in seconds per
cycle
so frequency is
psyc sorry
frequency is cycles per second so and
this is seconds per cycle
so frequency is just going to be 1 over
this
which is 1 over 2 pi
times the square root of k over m that's
the frequency
but
i have always had trouble memorizing
this and this you always use k over m m
over k all of that all you have to
really memorize is this and even that
you might even have an intuition as to
why it's true you can even go to the
differential equations if you want to
reprove it to yourself because if you
have this you really can answer any
question about the position
of of the mass at any time
the velocity of the mass at any time
just by taking the derivative or the
period or the frequency of the function
as long as you know how to take the
period and frequency of trig functions
and you could watch my videos or watch
my trig videos and to get a refresher on
that
one thing that's pretty interesting
about this is notice that the frequency
and the period right this is the period
of the function that's how long it takes
to do one cycle this is how many cycles
it does in one second both of them are
independent of a
so it doesn't matter i could stretch it
only a little bit like there and it'll
take the same amount of time to go back
and come back like that as it would if i
stretch it a lot it would just do that
if i stretch the if i stretched it just
a little bit the function would look
like this
i'll make sure i do this right
i'm not doing that right
edit undo
edit undo
if i just do it a little bit the
amplitude is going to be less but the
function is going to essentially do the
same thing
just going to do that
so it's going to take the same amount of
time to complete a cycle just have a
lower amplitude so that's that's
interesting to me that how much i
stretch it it's not going to make it
take longer or less time to complete one
cycle that's interesting
and so if i just told you that i
actually start having a object
compressed right so in that case
let's say my a is
-3
i have a spring constant of
let's say k is
oh i don't know 10
and i have a mass of
2 kilograms
then i can immediately tell you what the
equation of of the position as a
function of time at any point is it's
going to be
x of t will equal
i'm running out of space so x of t
would equal this is basic substitution
minus 3
cosine
of 10 divided by 2 right k over m is 5
so square root of 5 t
square root of 5 d i know that's
hard to read but you get the point i
just substitute it back but the
important thing is to know is this this
is i think the most important thing
and then if if given a trig function you
have trouble remembering how to figure
out the period or frequency although i
just think about when does when does
this when does this expression equal one
and then and then you could figure out
it's when right when does it equal one
or when does it equal zero and you can
figure out its period
if you don't have you can memorize this
formula for a period and this formula
for frequency but i think that might be
a waste of of your brain space anyway
i'll see you in the next video